on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
nouvelle vidéo pour dire faire un point
sur les rumeurs de l'iphone 14 alors
vous le savez les iphones sorte dans la
deuxième partie l'année il devrait
arriver normalement aller ça serait quoi
ça serait septembre et représenté 7 ans
arrivé octobre voire novembre en portant
la disponibilté disponibilité ça c'est
dur hier disponibilité des composants de
la crise des semi conducteurs donc tout
ça on le verra bien évidemment [ __ ]
mais ce qu'on commence à boire toute
vitesse qui est vachement intéressant et
bien c'est à quoi devrait ressembler ses
iphone 14 parce que si vous vous
intéressez au smartphone d'apple ils
n'ont pas vraiment évolué depuis le
lancement de l'iphone 10 cents en 2017
et il ya des choses qui restent vraiment
vraiment vraiment similaires à commencer
par cette question l'encoche on a
toujours cette très grande encore au
niveau des iphone même s'il ya des
évolutions au niveau du design au niveau
du dos même si effectivement les iphone
évolué avec de nouvelles puces même si
elles promotion' même s'il ya plein de
choses qui évoluent et ça c'est
vachement bien mais pour autant d'un
point de vue extérieur ça reste jusqu'à
présent toujours la même chose mais
rassurez vous rassurez vous c'est ça qui
va choix intéressant qu'à partir des
iphone 14 il devrait y avoir du
changement du lourd et ça c'est bon
[Musique]
12 passes au niveau du design et ça
c'est super alors avant de parler du
design il devrait y avoir un changement
au niveau des formats au niveau de la
dénomination alors si on regarde le line
up de 2020 en main l'iphone 13 min on à
l'iphone très long à l'iphone 13 pro les
fon 13 promax on a en gros trois formats
différents le mesnil petit lepreau et
l'iphone 13 c'est la même forme factor
et puis le pro mac c'est cette espèce de
très grosses bêtes que j'ai dans la main
j'utilise depuis un petit moment que
j'aime beaucoup donc ça c'est cool sauf
que l'iphone 13 min en tout cas le
format mini qu'on a vu arriver avec
l'iphone 12 c'est peut-être pas trop le
format qui fonctionnerait est a priori
apple se dire est bon pour le vend pas
des masses on va essayer de faire plus
simple et on va changer ça alors qu'est
ce qu'on veut vraiment arriver et bien
vraiment arriver un iphone 14 un iphone
14 mac c'est à dire l'iphone 14 mai en
plus grands un iphone 14 pro comme on
avait sur la gamme pro et puis un iphone
14 promax comme ce qu'on a également ici
sur l'iphone 13 pronax comme jamais sur
l'iphone 12 promax non en fait ça va
être des tailles d'écran qui vont être
sensiblement les mêmes entre le 14 mars
et la chine 14 promax donc sur l'iphone
14 f 14 pro on aurait dû 6,1 pouces
tandis que sur les gros modèles on
aurait dû 6,7 pouce au bout choisiriez
entrant 6,1 et un 6,7 5 paraît logique
parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
va plus dans l'idée d'avoir des grands
smartphone parce qu'on utilise beaucoup
pour me regarde des films des séries du
contenu réseaux sociaux multimédia &
company donc ça me paraît logique donc
ça on verra effectivement si ça arrive
ça veut dire que le plus petit iphone
disparaîtrait mais on devrait voir
arriver également cette année et bien un
nouvel iphone et ce alors j'imagine que
si on a un nouvel iphone et ce qui
pourrait ressembler à l'iphone 13 min en
termes de design sous la dénomination
est ce parce que le look du dernier
iphone et ceux de 2020 il est un peu old
school on se retrouve si on est vieux
look avec tom shayes dis donc ça ça
devrait changer on verrait arriver un
iphone et ce en 2022 qui aurait à peu
près le même look and feel de la même
esprit le même design que l'iphone 13 me
lis quoi c'est ce que je pense et ce que
j'espère et les autres iphone on aurait
2 tailles pour sachant qu'entre l'iphone
14h14 pro et bien on aurait probablement
un peu plus de ram on irait plus loin en
termes de photos avec l'ajout d'un tel
objectif mais ça on va parler en
quelques instants et entre l'iphone 14
mars à l'iphone 14 pronax mais ça serait
sensiblement la même différence donc
voilà ça c'est cool mais le touquet
vachement intéressant je monte sur mon
écran c'est qu'il doit y avoir un tout
nouveau design et ça c'est plutôt
chouette c'est à dire la disparition de
l'encoche alors c'est vrai je vous le
disais l'encoche aller là depuis 2010
est donc c'est vrai que ça me paraîtrait
logique qu'on la voit disparaître alors
il ya plusieurs propositions il y en a
une à laquelle j'adhère l'autre pas trop
trop ce qu'on vous montre ses seins
petits points sont globalement j'y crois
pas je veux bien qu'apple ait réussi à
planquer dans l'infrarouge sous l'écran
pour venir vous faire du fayçali parce
qu'on garderait fayçali dans tous les
cas ça me paraît pas très logique
d'avoir juste un petit point sont comme
ça il ya une autre proposition c'est
éventuellement un poinçon bull un peu
plus grand je suis pas non plus
extrêmement convaincu et on retrouve
l'idée du pinson mais j'y crois pas des
masses ça j'y crois davantage par contre
c'est à dire bien vous aurez votre
caméra ici ça serait une 12 mégapixels
plan qui en caméra de celle fille puis à
vous retrouverez y est sur le côté eh
bien regardez ça serait la partie pour
faith heidi vous reviendrez avoir de
l'infrarouge ans a réduit quand même
c'est quand même vachement mieux
qu'avoir juste l'encoche qui est quand
même vachement proéminente c'est vrai
excusez-moi l'encoche c'est vrai que je
vous en ai beaucoup parlé en disant bon
flanc gauche n'est pas au fond on s'y
habitue clairement mais vu ce qu'on
arrive à trouver aujourd'hui sur android
avec des canards qui sont plus petit ça
serait bien qu apple avance là-dessus
donc ça ça pourrait être la grosse
révolution de l'iphone 4 sont pas des
iphone 14 et puis voyez après on nous
fait cette proposition comme ça c'est
bien chaud ça vachement mieux et bien
dégagé le poinçon j'y crois pas des
masses et là ça serait a priori alors
j'ai de bons retours des pincettes quand
je parle de ça parce que ça reste
vraiment des rumeurs il y a un petit peu
tôt au moins le temps de cette vidéo
mais ça pourrait être ça on retrouverait
un écran une protection d'écran un
module d'écran je ne sais pas les
savoirs votre petit point c'est aussi
votre module caméra ici pour avoir fait
ça dit donc ça me paraît assez
intéressant ça pourrait être plutôt cool
avoir bien évidemment si tout ça se
confirme une autre rumeur fait à la
chasse un poil plus épais pour venir
intégrer 'face à il dit sous l'écran bon
pas convaincu mais on verra sinon le
design serait similaire à ceux des
iphone 13 on aurait sensiblement la même
chose la seule différence que vous
auriez je sais pas si vous l'avez déjà
vu et bien c'est des années au niveau
des modules photo on aura quelque chose
de beaucoup plus plat parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas extrêmement
plat on a quand même un petit relief un
blog photo qui peut paraître un peu
grand pour certains qui moi me pose pas
de problème parce que de toute façon je
viens mettre une coque de protection qui
laissait une coque monsieur heureux donc
je mets ma comme donc ça équilibre tout
ça mais pour ceux qui aiment l'utiliser
sans coque notamment mon peu de jb qui
fait ça eh bien regardez vous auriez ici
un design complètement plat ça pourrait
avoir un sens et ça c'est vraiment qu'on
retrouve un petit peu partout il est
d'abord un module photo pl de tous les
côtés donc ça me paraît assez logique et
on verra effectivement si ça arrive
bientôt d'ailleurs j'invite à venir vous
abonner pour tout savoir sur l'actuelle
à d'autres marques ea compagnie cliquer
sur le petit bouton rouge qu'elle a si
les rouches et vous n'êtes pas bonne et
surtout actionner la cloche pour être
totti fait dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera et ça c'est très très cool il
ya une autre rumeur qui fait état de
tochigi qui pourrait arriver planqué
directement sous votre écran tout en
gardant fayçal dit je sais pas je suis
pas convaincu peut-être pas pour
l'iphone 14 peut-être pour les iphone 15
bon ça ça me paraît pas hyper hyper
logique on verra si ça arrive en tout
cas pourquoi pas comme je vous le disais
au niveau des écrans seraient du site
ainsi cette poussée de la techno oled lt
paix au kivu permettrait d'avoir le pro
motion le promotion c'est le taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz sur toute
la gamme les 4 iphone cette année aurait
un taux de rafraîchissement variable
allant jusqu'à 120 hertz a pourrait être
plutôt cool on aurait toujours des haut
parleurs stéréo ça changerait pas grand
chose là dessus du bluetooth 5.2 on
retrouverait la puce à 16 bionique gravé
en 4 nanomètres vous permettra bien
évidemment d'abord un gain de
performance et puis surtout d'économiser
aussi de l'énergie de par la finesse de
gravure ou devrait avoir si giga de ram
sur toute la gamme et pourquoi pas si
giga de ram sur l'iphone 14 et l'iphone
14 max et puis monter jusqu'à 8 gigas de
ram sur le 14 pro et 14 promax je suis
pas convaincu du bon c'est giga de ram
partout je le vois bien après un peu
qu'il faut vraiment savoir qui est
extrêmement important il faut pas venir
comparer le nombre de giga de ram que
vous avez avec un iphone et avec un
autre smartphone android parce qu'ici
tout est complètement développé par
apple c'est sûr optimisée d'un point de
vue matériel avec la puce maison avec un
logiciel maison tout est développé par
apple dont tout fonctionne bien donc
avec moins de ram on arrive à faire des
trucs qui fonctionne vachement bien et
ça c'est la très grosse force d'apple on
dirait sur un stockage de 64 giga de
stockage jusqu'à 1 tera voit peut-être
une rumeur fait état de deux terrasses
sûrs impro max sait pas s'il y aurait
vraiment un sens alors dû d'otéra mais
peut-être parce qu'on pourrait venir
filmer ici jusqu'en 8 k et si on fait de
l'américain dans des fichiers un peu
plus lourd il faut venir les stocker un
terrain c'est déjà énorme 512 ça ira
d'ailleurs très bien mais de terra
pourquoi pas si on veut en faire un
usage professionnel d'ailleurs je sais
pas si vous cesserez un usage
professionnel ou si c'est plus de l'usaj
de divertissement gaming quelques photos
à partager sur le réseau d'ailleurs dit
le mot en bas on commentaires et on
pourrait avoir un refroidissement agents
de rabat peu intéressant on aurait de la
charge à 25 watts et du magsafe c'est à
dire de la charge son fils 15 watts bien
évidemment ios 16 d'ailleurs on en
parlera des oss un peu plus tard et ça
serait la fin des capteur de 12
mégapixels on aurait ici et bien des
capteurs 2,48 mégapixels 48 48 48 alors
si l'on regarde l'iphone 14 et l'iphone
14 max on aurait que deux capteurs ont
nourri un grand-angle et un ultra grand
angle au téléobjectif serait uniquement
pour les gammes pro le 14 pro et 14 pour
au max comme on peut le voir ici mais on
serait partout en 48 mégapixels comme on
était chez apple partout en 12
mégapixels alors qu'elle veut que le
gros bénéfices d'être ici sur deux 48
mégapixels versus de 12 mégapixels et
bien c'est plus vous avez de pixels
pelouse et pouvoir venir capter de
lumière grâce à une technologie qui
s'appelle le pixel baning à savoir que
vous venez regrouper quatre pixels en un
c'est pas tout nouveau on a beaucoup
parlé sur android mais ici au niveau des
iphone on l'avait pas ça pour être
vachement intéressant pour les photos en
conditions de faible luminosité
permettrait d'aller encore un peu plus
loin et de capter plus de lumière et
lorsque vous ne seriez pas en condition
de faible luminosité vous pourriez avoir
une meilleure définition niveau de votre
image bon ok pas ça pourrait être pas
mal aussi il ya une rumeur qui fait état
d'un potentiel zoom périscopique au
niveau des modèles pro mais peut-être
pas pour cette année peut-être pour 2023
sur l'iphone 15 allez savoir ça reste
très flou cette histoire on aura bien
évidemment une caméra lidar et je
voulais dit la caméra celle fillon 12
mégapixels alors on aura toujours de
l'ultra wide band pour venir utiliser
ces airtag un modem 5 g de qualcomm
c'est le x 65 qui vous permettra d'or
des débits jusqu'à 10 gigabits par
seconde bon ok qui vous permettra aussi
également d'avoir une connectivité
d'urgence via le satellite à veut dire
que si vous êtes un endroit où vous ne
captez pas eh bien vous pourrez venir
envoyer un message via le satellite aux
secours ou alors à l'un de vos contacts
pour dire je suis là j'ai un problème fo
vient me chercher alors imaginez vous
êtes en plein milieu du sahara y a pas
de borne ça pour être pratique faute
d'abord un téléphone satellitaire avec
vous parce qu'on a globalement pas avec
soirée notre côté on n'est pas souvent
dans le sahara bah si votre cas des
reniflements commentaires ça pourrait
également être la fin de la carte sim
une tiroirs de cartes si vous n'auriez
plus de cartes insérées vous connecte
auriez directement près votre opérateur
vous rentreriez vos informations et vous
pourriez avoir votre ici mais ça
pourrait être aussi intéressant
permettrait de libérer de la place à
terre du smartphone et de venir ajouter
un poil plus en étanchéité puisqu'on
aurait pas un petit tiroir conviendrait
ouvrir à boire également du wifi 6e et
puis il ya un truc qui est intéressant
c'est que ça a été annoncé c'est
officiel on va plus avoir les écouteurs
filaires les irp ods ne seront plus
intégrés directement avec votre iphone
parce qu'une loi française qui est passé
d'ailleurs la france est toujours
l'exception d'ailleurs si vous avez
acheté un iphone dans les deux dernières
années vous aviez votre petite boîte
d'iphone et vous aviez en plus une sur
bois avec vos écouteurs là vous n'aurez
plus votre sur boîte vous n'aurez plus
d'écouteurs alors l'idée c'est de
réduire l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique en france je le comprends et
c'est vraiment bien il faut aller dans
le bon sens mais rappelons-nous pourquoi
est-ce que la france avait dit on va
garder les irp ods et bien tout
simplement pour limiter l'exposition aux
ondes donc ça veut dire que
l'environnement l'emportent versus
l'exposition aux ondes ou alors on dit
est ce que les gens vont venir d'eux
même gardé leur airpod six ans non alors
ce qu'elles vont devenir eux-mêmes à
acheter aux écouteurs sans fil de la
même manière qu'on va aujourd'hui
acheter notre bloc de charges bon en
tout cas voilà c'est un choix qui est
fait c'est une grosse évidence qu'il
faut venir protéger l'environnement mais
je pense qu'il faut aussi venir protéger
les gens et le fait d'avoir ces
écouteurs c'était pas mal pour des
personnes qui achètent déjà des folles
qui coûtait déjà relativement cher leur
permettre d'aborder écouteurs filaires
avec pour moi ce n'est pas un luxe mais
bon voilà c'est comme ça et puis il ya
une autre option qui pourrait
potentiellement arriver c'est la
détection d'accidents voiture là car
crash détéction ce qui fait que c'est
grâce à votre accéléromètre si vous avez
un accident et bien votre smartphone
pourrait pirée et ça va il ya un
problème et si vous répondez pas ici un
problème on appelle les secours ça
pourrait pas mal je vous dis des iphone
qui sera annoncée potentiellement en
septembre en octobre pour une arrivée
octobre novembre on suivra ça bien
évidemment les tarifs resteront toujours
à mon avis sensiblement les mêmes avec
un tarif d'entrée en un petit peu moins
de 1000 euros et puis après on montre et
200 euros ans en europe jusqu'à arriver
au smartphone le plus chiant donc voilà
ce qu'on arrive aujourd'hui à savoir le
portrait robot des iphone 14 pas ce que
vous en pensez vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter par un iphone 14 est-ce
que vous avez déjà un iphone et est ce
que c'est une question vachement
intéressante est ce que le fait d'avoir
une encoche vous a dit moi je passe aux
iphone parce que j'aime pas lent cochon
ça pas beau et que aujourd'hui sur
android et bien y'a pas dans le coche et
d'un système qui me plaisent bien ça ça
me plait pas des masses mais si apple
arrive à supprimer ce temps koch est ce
que je pourrais aller chez eux ils
voulaient marquer en commentaire ça
vachement intéressant nous on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer bien
évidemment a parlé dès qu'il ya plein de
choses qui arrivent c'est une année très
remplie je vous dit probablement un
iphone est ce qui devrait arriver en
2022 on va voir à quoi il va ressembler
réellement mais ce pourrait être
vachement intéressant à faire des
nouveautés au niveau des ipad en ipad
pro qu'il va arriver bientôt peut-être
un autre ipad r eyeos 16 bref plein de
trucs super cool du côté d'apple mais
pas que ça c'est chouette on s'embrasse
pour les soigner vous beaucoup d'amour
et à bientôt des bisous 15
[Musique]